[Music]
so for someone that's you to profession
I think the best thing to do is start
new projects and do things that you
enjoy doing because if you're doing
something you enjoy doing you're gonna
have such a better learning experience
by doing that look for mentorship
sometimes you just need to ask and you
will be surprised how many people are
willing to help with that learn the
basic like learn the JavaScript learn
the CSS learn the HTML yeah I kind of
agree like I went through like so long
and I didn't know like HTTP and nothing
messed up so much of my understanding
but I still think if I stopped and tried
to learn HTTP that early on I would have
just abandoned the whole thing because I
wouldn't have you also have to be
realistic like many people start with a
job and in that job we use frameworks
you probably don't have the time to
learn the basic side I'm not saying like
you're doing it wrong if you not learn
the basics first each other I recommend
I think it's time well invested I
recommend speaking at conferences like
before you even get a job in tax speak
at a conference just make it up because
it's really good for your profile right
that's how you get it up in the first
thing exactly fake it till you make it
fake it till you make it
this is my first time in days gone
Budapest
it's amazing I love the diversity over
here as an experience wise it's amazing
and the things I'm learning here is also
very great because though I'm an infra
engineer there are certain concepts
which are relevant to a DevOps engineer
as well like how you should communicate
to your architects how you should work
in collaboration with your product
manager and the way you build your
products maybe we can also think of
having accessibility in DevOps whatever
products we build in so yeah it's quite
relevant Jay's computer past is my first
conference as an attendee and my very
first conference as a speaker it's all
new to me and I had a wonderful time
thank you all so much my experience of
just confidence I've really good so far
we've been able to travel here with the
whole family got a lovely family room at
the hotel the food that's been good and
all of the communications and the help
I've gotten as a speaker has been that
blew my mind
for me a very humbling experience to be
here today this is one of the places
where the people are so nice and so open
I love the community here last time I
was at just come for the past I got hit
in the eye by an hdmi dongle what a
great memory yeah I think my favorite
memory is my very first talk as a
Googler with a J s con tu 2015 I was a
bad talk but it was a great community I
wasn't there no you weren't
[Music]
it's my first time in any JSF
conferences and it's been amazing I
don't know it's amazing content all the
time it goes outside of what you would
expect from a tech conference it's my
favorite talk so far has been the talk
of this guy that works with refugee aid
camp which is something we would never
have access to this like anywhere else
and I think like that alongside with the
community here that seems to be very
friendly and very respectful I'm not
having the bless like I'm having the
best time
my favorite jscotth memory was talking
to the organizer of J's conf Eve and
kind of hearing his authentic part for
the conference and how he wants to get
everybody involved irrespective of race
and gender and orientation this it's a
conference for everybody when it when I
think of J's conf I think inclusion
family community so none of those are
technical
[Music]